Shure: 你给的是那个靖蝎啊
Shure: You gave that to Jing Xie.
Shure: 你被这种人
Shure: You're being handled by this kind of person.
Nicous: 已经红了不知道
Nicous: Already red, don't know.
Tasha:就差几个立场足
Tasha: Just a few stands short.
Katrina: 就往就往这上面放你想要压的就行
Katrina: Just place it where you want to press.
Shure: 我想压压一个哎
Shure: I want to press one, hey.
Tasha:一个两个还差一个立场足
Tasha: One or two, still short one stand.
Tasha:还差一个无敌啊
Tasha: Still short one invincible.
Katrina: 这个我感觉也这样吧
Katrina: I think it should be like this.
Katrina: 就这样摆着就行
Katrina: Just place it like this.
Tasha:哈哈他他打不过我
Tasha: Haha, he can't beat me.
俢硕:拿一个有设计感一点的
Shure: Get one with more design.
Tasha:然后他还可以再跟我玩
Tasha: Then he can still play with me.
Katrina: 你那里有几片啊Lucy
Katrina: How many pieces do you have there, Lucia?
Lucia:嗯我下下面那个是4片
Lucia: Hmm, the one below is 4 pieces.
Lucia:不过是小的
Lucia: But it's small.
Lucia:上面只有
Lucia: On top only...
Lucia:我打算先放两个因为第一次压
Lucia: I plan to put two first because it's the first press.
Katrina: 我说因为木板啊
Katrina: I'm talking about the wooden board.
Lucia:木板木板只有一个
Lucia: Wooden board, there's only one.
Tasha:嗯乌迪尔
Tasha: Hmm, Udyr.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia:不过纸有很多
Lucia: But there's a lot of paper.
Katrina:  还有一个木板呢哦在这
Katrina: There's still one wooden board, oh, here it is.
Tasha: 123 嗯
Tasha: 123 Hmm
Tasha:内脏桌也差一个
Tasha: We're missing an organ table too.
Shure: 然后这个可以摘是吗
Shure: And we can pick this one, right?
Katrina: 可以啊但感觉这叶子不是很好看
Katrina: Yeah, but I feel like these leaves don't look very nice.
Tasha:卖谁啊
Tasha: Who are we selling to?
Katrina: 这种小花就可以直接摘
Katrina: You can just pick these little flowers directly.
Jake:怎么还
Jake: How come...
Tasha:谁卖谁啊
Tasha: Who's selling to whom?
Jake:还你是挂了吗
Jake: Are you just hanging out?
Katrina: 我还有一个东西要做
Katrina: I still have something to do.
Tasha:卖谁啊
Tasha: Who are we selling to?
Katrina: 我天呐
Katrina: Oh my god.
Katrina: 这辈子没干过活这么多手工活
Katrina: I've never done this much handcraft work in my life.
Jake:现在就剩他和人机打的
Jake: Now it's just him and the AI playing.
Katrina: 从小幼儿园的时候上手工课就不会做
Katrina: Since kindergarten, I've never been good at handcraft class.
Jake:哦一个真人咯
Jake: Oh, a real person then.
Shure: 就不听
Shure: Just not listening.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 就给糖给别人让别人做
Katrina: I would just give candy to others to make them do it.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina: 从小就会
Katrina: I've been doing that since I was little.
Katrina: 这种雇佣劳动力
Katrina: This kind of hired labor.
Tasha:嗯应该不会吧
Tasha: Hmm, probably not.
Katrina: 然后就很多年没有做过手了
Katrina: And then I haven't done handcraft work for many years.
Shure: 这压出来是一整张是吗
Shure: Does it come out as a whole sheet?
Katrina: 没有压出来
Katrina: It didn't come out.
Lucia:像这样
Lucia: Like this.
Lucia:就是它会变成一个一个干花
Lucia: It turns into individual dried flowers.
俢硕:啊 啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Shure: 嗨
Shure: Hi.
Tasha:你看啊
Tasha: Look.
Tasha:它启动是慢
Tasha: It's slow to start.
Tasha:因为我带的装备不对
Tasha: Because I'm wearing the wrong gear.
Shure: 我以为是构成一幅画呢
Shure: I thought it would form a picture.
Tasha:不是带了个偷吗
Tasha: Didn't you bring a thief?
Katrina:  那那这些棒干了以后
Katrina: So, after these sticks dry...
Shure: 那它这些棒
Shure: What about these sticks?
Katrina: 再自己拼拼成一副画
Katrina: You can piece them together into a picture.
俢硕:棒有什么用呢
Shure: What use are the sticks?
Lucia:当然你也可以发挥你的创造力
Lucia: Of course, you can also use your creativity.
Katrina: 然后之后你就拿它干
Katrina: And then you just use it.
Katrina: 了以后它颜色也保存了
Katrina: After that, the color stays.
Katrina: 你就拿胶水粘那种明信片啊
Katrina: You just use glue to stick it on a postcard or something.
Nicous: 他是不是在砍你呀
Nicous: Is he trying to scam you?
Katrina:  或者什么都可以
Katrina: Or anything else, really.
Katrina:  或者夹玻璃片
Katrina: Or sandwich it between glass pieces.
Tasha:他还有这种本领
Tasha: He has skills like that?
Tasha:他怎么可能会有这种
Tasha: How could he have such...
Nicous: 卖了卖乌迪尔
Nicous: Sold Udyr.
Tasha:卖谁
Tasha: Sold who?
Nicous: 卖乌迪尔
Nicous: Sold Udyr.
Nicous: 冲 冲
Nicous: Charge, charge!
Katrina: 没然后了
Katrina: That's it.
Katrina: 就把你压扁就行
Katrina: Just flatten it.
Katrina: 不是你多放点呗
Katrina: No, you need to add more.
Shure: 什么叫多放一点
Shure: What do you mean by add more?
Nicous: 这就是你的磁塔
Nicous: This is your magnet tower.
Katrina: 这么多地方的
Katrina: So many places.
俢硕:啊都可以利用
Shure: Yeah, you can use all of them.
Tasha:这就是你的磁塔
Tasha: This is your magnet tower.
Shure: 那这些棒也要压一下吗
Shure: Do we need to flatten these sticks too?
Nicous: 没意思没意思
Nicous: Boring, boring.
Tasha:都受不了了
Tasha: Can't take it anymore.
Katrina: 我觉得第一层先压薄的吧
Katrina: I think we should flatten the first layer thin.
Katrina: 这个放厚点
Katrina: This one should be thicker.
Katrina: 先压薄的就一片一片摆上去
Katrina: Flatten the thin ones first, layer by layer.
Tasha:盖上一些小罐子
Tasha: Cover it with some small jars.
Nicous: 我靠
Nicous: Oh my gosh.
Tasha:这就是你的
Tasha: This is yours.
Tasha:要卖力曾主
Tasha: Put in some effort.
Tasha:没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Katrina: 被妈妈送过去上那种兴趣班的
Katrina: Sent by mom to those interest classes.
Katrina: 那种小孩
Katrina: Those kids.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 坐着乖乖的
Katrina: Sitting obediently.
Katrina: 你妈
Katrina: Your mom...
俢硕:毫无感情是吧
Shure: Completely emotionless, right?
Katrina: 对毫无感情
Katrina: Yeah, completely emotionless.
Katrina: 等你妈来接你回家的
Katrina: Waiting for your mom to pick you up.
Katrina: 我是那老师监督
Katrina: I was that teacher supervising.
Shure: 然后呢
Shure: And then?
Shure: 铺完了然后呢
Shure: After laying it, then what?
Katrina:  铺完了
Katrina: After laying it
Katrina:  然后就没有然后了
Katrina: Then there's nothing more to do
Katrina:  然后就把板子盖上
Katrina: Then just cover it with the board
Katrina:  就
Katrina: Just
俢硕：怎么怎么盖
Shure: How do you cover it?
Shure:  这个东西
Shure: This thing
Katrina:  我看看再放一点
Katrina: Let me see, and then add a little more
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah
Katrina:  放满充分利用
Katrina: Fill it completely, make full use of it
Shure:  好好的轩老师
Shure: Alright, alright, Teacher Xuan
Shure: 好的宣好老师
Shure: Alright, Teacher Xuan
Katrina:  怎么都叫我轩老师
Katrina: Why do you all call me Teacher Xuan?
Shure: 又忘了你姓啥了
Shure: Forgot your last name again
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah
Shure:  没有没有记着呢记着呢
Shure: No, no, I remember, I remember
Shure: 节目效果懂吗
Shure: It's for the show, you know?
Katrina:  懂懂懂
Katrina: Got it, got it
Katrina:  主要是之前那男生也叫我轩老师啊
Katrina: Mainly because that guy before also called me Teacher Xuan
Shure:  完了勾起你不好意思回忆了是吗
Shure: Did it bring back some embarrassing memories?
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes
俢硕:好的轩老师
Shure: Alright, Teacher Xuan
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia:目达到了
Lucia: Goal achieved
俢硕:轩老师
Shure: Teacher Xuan
Katrina: 哈哈哈受不了了
Katrina: Hahaha, I can't take it
Katrina: 她老师也这么叫我
Katrina: Her teacher also calls me that
俢硕：嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe
Katrina: 这你就不知道了吧
Katrina: You didn't know that, did you?
Katrina: 昨天晚上新讲的一个
Katrina: Told you a new one last night
Shure: 哦这个啊
Shure: Oh, that one
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Nicous: 来对了
Nicous: Just in time
Shure: 就是每天晚上解锁一个新角色
Shure: It's like unlocking a new character every night
Nicous: 昨天晚上解锁了
Nicous: Unlocked last night
Shure: 解锁了就到时候七个葫芦娃
Shure: Unlock and eventually, seven calabash brothers
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn
Nicous: 昨天晚上我没来
Nicous: I wasn't here last night
Shure: 就是白雪公主和七个小矮人
Shure: It's like Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs.
Nicous: 我的人物版图上就真的太可惜了
Nicous: It's really a pity on my character map.
Nicous: 现在那种点播群只要你想查什么都 能查
Nicous: Now in those on-demand groups, you can find anything you want.
Shure:  你先查查
Shure: You check first.
Shure:  把王爱媛的所有名单调出来
Shure: Pull up all the lists for Wang Ai Yuan.
俢硕：你快快调一下
Shure: Quickly, pull them up.
Nicous: 调你的 美女
Nicous: Pull them up, beauty.
Shure: 美女 哎呀
Shure: Beauty, oh dear.
Shure:  跟杨老板申请经费
Shure: Apply for funding from Jake.
Katrina:  你是人啊
Katrina: Are you human?
Shure:  我是狗好吧
Shure: I'm a dog, okay?
Shure: 借了个纸你去做狗
Shure: Borrow some paper and you become a dog.
Shure:  然后呢然后呢
Shure: Then what? Then what?
Shure:  快下一步是什么
Shure: What's the next step?
Katrina:  就上一个板子压他就好了
Katrina: Just put a board on top and it's done.
Katrina: 这就赶走了
Katrina: Then it's done.
Katrina: 然后我觉得可以再再夹一层
Katrina: Then I think we can add another layer.
Katrina: 嗯养老
Katrina: Mm, for retirement.
Katrina: 生活
Katrina: Life.
俢硕:就跟养老院似的
Shure: Just like a retirement home.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 哦这是汉堡的
Shure: Oh, this is Hamburg's.
Shure:  第一次没有
Shure: The first time didn't work.
Katrina:  呃
Katrina: Ugh.
Shure:  他散了
Shure: It fell apart.
Katrina:  预示着我的爱情
Katrina: It symbolizes my love.
Katrina:  这样翻哈哈哈
Katrina: Like this, hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈好的
Katrina: Haha, okay.
Shure: 好的轩老师哈哈哈
Shure: Okay, Mr. Xuan, hahaha.
Katrina: 受不了你了
Katrina: I can't stand you.
Jake:什么老师
Jake: What teacher?
Katrina: 是他叫我轩老师
Katrina: He calls me Mr. Xuan.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: 他叫我轩老师
Katrina: He calls me Mr. Xuan.
Shure: 叫她轩老师
Shure: He calls her Mr. Xuan.
Katrina: 他是那种上补习班的小孩
Katrina: He's like a kid attending tutoring classes.
Katrina:  然后我是旁边老师
Katrina: And I'm the teacher next to him.
Katrina:  他等他妈接他回家吃饭哦
Katrina: Waiting for his mom to pick him up for dinner.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 你直接坐一下不就得了
Shure: Just sit down for a bit.
Lucia:不行你要把这袋子拉紧
Lucia: No, you need to tighten this bag.
Lucia:哦你这意思我坐在上面拉
Lucia: Oh, you mean I should sit on it and pull?
Shure:  对什么叫坐在上面拉
Shure: Yes, what do you mean sit on it and pull?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Katrina: 好奇怪
Katrina: So weird.
Lucia:这句话能删掉吗
Lucia: Can we delete that sentence?
Katrina: AI刚才了点什么东西
Katrina: The AI just caught something.
Jake:翻译过去
Jake: Translate it.
Jake:一没有一点问题
Jake: No problem at all.
Shure: 你不坐在上面拉也行
Shure: You don't have to sit on it to pull either.
Jake:没有一点问题
Jake: No problem at all.
Katrina: 你做这个吧你来做这个行吗
Katrina: You do this, can you handle it?
Jake:你要做这个
Jake: You need to do this.
Katrina: 你做这个行吗
Katrina: Can you handle this?
Shure: 你在拉里拉萨
Shure: You do it in Lhasa.
Shure: 你在哪里拉随便你
Shure: You do it wherever, it's up to you.
Jake:什么怎怎么翻译这个
Jake: How do we translate this?
Shure:  哈哈我不知道这叫什么
Shure: Haha, I don't know what this is called.
Lucia:别吧朋友们
Lucia: Please don't, guys.
Jake:什么叫做
Jake: What do you mean?
Lucia:我的一世英名啊
Lucia: My reputation!
Shure: sit sit谁
Shure: Sit sit who?
Jake:谁谁坐
Jake: Who sits?
Lucia:就这个我刚才想把它拉紧然后
Lucia: I was just trying to tighten it and then...
Lucia:修硕说我可以
Lucia: Shure said I could...
Lucia:就是坐在上面这样可以压得更紧
Lucia: ...sit on it to press it tighter.
Jake:你sitting on the board是吧
Jake: You're sitting on the board, right?
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia:然后我说不行就这个东西要拉紧
Lucia: Then I said no, it needs to be tightened.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, okay.
Shure: 我也可以坐在上面
Shure: I can sit on it too.
Jake:P Puling with you sitting on it right啊OK
Jake: Pulling with you sitting on it, right? Okay.
Shure: 啊你先铺铺点
Shure: Ah, you go ahead.
Shure: 这个还可以给他
Shure: This can still be...
Shure: 那什么给他谐音怎么POL
Shure: What's the homophone for POL?
Shure: 噗那个噗脸
Shure: Puh, that puh face.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Lucia:我靠哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my god, hahaha.
Shure: 你这这中文是互通的有没有
Shure: This Chinese is interchangeable, isn't it?
Jake:有有有有
Shure: 你不做完一遍了吗
Shure:  你怎么还需要学啊
Shure:  这谁的花
Shure:  我就给人家薅了
Katrina:  我的全被我剪光了
Shure:  这个是谁的
Katrina:  我的呀哦
Jake: 嗯
Lucia:这个真的要弄的很紧吗
Jake:什么时候做狗
Lucia:做什么什么时候做狗
Lucia:做狗谁不会啊哈哈哈
Jake: 把什么
Jake: 我我有
Jake: 那试试
Shure:  不是他那个
Jake:好
Jake:哪有现在
Katrina: 是这样干的
Jake:什么4点的什么
Jake:现在有四点
Jake: It's 4 o'clock now.
Katrina: 问你一个问题
Katrina: Let me ask you a question.
Shure: 你说
Shure: Go ahead.
Lucia:哎那那哦我去
Lucia: Hey, wait, oh, I'm going.
Lucia:怎么抓在这啊
Lucia: How do I catch it here?
Lucia:我先简单的尝试一下
Lucia: I'll try it simply first.
Shure: oh
Shure: Oh.
Shure: do do do do do do steal
Shure: Do do do do do do steal.
Lucia:这两边不一样紧哎
Lucia: These two sides have different tightness.
Shure: 你看看是不是还得坐上
Shure: See if you need to sit down.
Lucia:我这叫从善如流
Lucia: I call this going with the flow.
Lucia:现在差不多了
Lucia: It's about right now.
Lucia:good
Lucia: Good.
Lucia:让我看看它明天会变成什么样子
Lucia: Let me see what it looks like tomorrow.
Lucia:做法
Lucia: The method.
Jake:哈哈哈什么梗啊什么梗啊什么梗
Jake: Hahaha, what's the joke? What's the joke? What's the joke?
Katrina: 他这人可贱了
Katrina: He's so annoying.
Shure: 我就可以
Shure: I can handle it.
Jake:说来听听
Jake: Tell us more.
Shure: 就可以大家都听不懂的状态下
Shure: When everyone can't understand it
Shure: 然后精准的攻击到他
Shure: Then precisely attack him
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure
Shure: 哇我这些都开了
Shure: Wow, I have unlocked all of these
Lucia:Good
Lucia: Good
Shure: 还有我本来就是开的呀
Shure: And I had them unlocked originally
Shure: 发青春
Shure: Youth unleashed
Katrina: 你也要耕鸡
Katrina: You need to farm chickens too
Katrina: 拿你的故事来换
Katrina: Trade your story for it
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 你你顶多做母鸡
Shure: You can at most be a hen
Katrina: 所以快递是他等会寄送过来是吧
Katrina: So the delivery will be sent over later, right?
Lucia:我们的笔到了吗
Lucia: Has our pen arrived?
Lucia:我也没见过
Lucia: I haven't seen it either
Katrina: 你要不跟他们去看小狗
Katrina: Why don't you go check the puppies with them?
Jake:走带我们去吧
Jake: Come on, take us there
Katrina: 就很近很近
Katrina: It's very close, very close
Katrina: 走溜一圈嘛
Katrina: Let's take a walk around
Lucia:可以换个鞋吗
Lucia: Can I change my shoes?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure
Lucia:我想穿拖鞋去
Lucia: I want to wear slippers
Lucia:可能拖鞋会走着走着掉在路上
Lucia: The slippers might fall off while walking
Katrina: 让我穿睡衣就能去
Katrina: Let me wear pajamas, and I can go
Lucia:这个放哪
Lucia: Where should I put this?
Katrina: 我说这能穿睡衣去吗
Katrina: I mean, can I wear pajamas to go?
Lucia:这就放这吧
Lucia: Just put it here
Lucia:回来还得拼我的这个玩意
Lucia: I still need to assemble this thing when I get back
Lucia:你在叫我吗
Lucia: Are you calling me?
Jake:没有没有薇薇
Jake: No, no, Tasha
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:嚯哦
Jake: Whoa
Tasha:从此进我的房间就要脱鞋子了
Tasha: From now on, you need to take off your shoes to enter my room
Lucia:哎你的地毯已经到了
Lucia: Hey, your carpet has arrived
Lucia:好好看
Lucia: It looks great
Lucia:好多巴胺
Lucia: So much dopamine
Lucia:我目前到的材料还没有一个是蓝色的
Lucia: None of the materials I've received so far are blue
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia:然后我让我许愿我的计划能顺利进行
Lucia: I wish my plan goes smoothly
杨老板 是的你要不买点颜料
Jake: Yeah, why don't you buy some paint?
Lucia:我中途修一下计划
Lucia: I'll adjust the plan midway.
Lucia:然后到时候
Lucia: And then by that time...
Jake:你现在是什么颜色
Jake: What color are you now?
Lucia:我现在都是白色的
Lucia: I'm all white right now.
Jake:白色
Jake: White.
Lucia:但我得它明天应该会到了
Lucia: But I think it should arrive by tomorrow.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:至少那个鱼网
Lucia: At least the fishnet.
Tasha:这和我房间很配
Tasha: This matches my room well.
Katrina: 笑死
Katrina: So funny.
Tasha:哦要出门了是吧
Tasha: Oh, are we heading out?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:我们要看狗了
Jake: We're going to see the dog.
Lucia:我感觉看狗不能穿在脚上
Lucia: I feel like you shouldn't wear that to see the dog.
Tasha:为什么我们一群人要看一只狗
Tasha: Why do we need a group to see one dog?
Tasha:就感觉他是一个
Tasha: It feels like he is...
Tasha:孤独的需要被看望的
Tasha: ...lonely and needs to be visited.
Jake:因为我们要做狗
Jake: Because we need to be the dog.
Lucia:是让AI之间建立一些逻辑联系
Lucia: It's to establish some logical connections between AIs.
Tasha:空巢老人一样
Tasha: Like an empty nest elder.
Lucia:因为我们一会可能要做狗
Lucia: Because we might need to be the dog later.
Jake:是对 我们
Jake: Yes, we...
Tasha:是吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake:是我们要做狗
Jake: Yes, we need to be the dog.
Jake:好我们要学习怎么做狗
Jake: Okay, we need to learn how to be a dog.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:我们要跟狗请教一下怎么做狗
Jake: We need to ask the dog how to be a dog.
Lucia:一本正
Lucia: Seriously.
Tasha:那我要做一只可爱小狗
Tasha: Then I'll be a cute little dog.
Jake:小狗 好嘞
Jake: A little dog, sure.
Tasha:所以昨天为什么要抢红包
Tasha: So why did we snatch red envelopes yesterday?
Tasha:明明这是用
Tasha: Obviously, it's...
Katrina: 手速得来
Katrina: A matter of hand speed.
Jake:因为他没有钱是吧
Jake: Because he has no money, right?
Jake:那提前拿到钱嘛多好
Jake: So it's great to get money in advance.
Shure: 棍棒底下出孝子
Shure: A filial child comes from the rod.
Shure: 严师出高徒
Shure: A strict teacher produces outstanding students.
Katrina: 哇这个大花瓣
Katrina: Wow, this big petal.
Shure: 这个话不无道理
Shure: There's some truth to that saying.
Shure: 你给他拆了
Shure: You dismantled it.
Katrina: 不小心掉出一片
Katrina: Oops, I accidentally dropped a piece.
Shure: 我就想让他整一个这样子
Shure: I just wanted him to make one like this.
Katrina: 整一个这个压不了啊
Katrina: Making one like this won't press it down.
Katrina: 除非你一天到晚用屁股坐着他才能压
Katrina: Unless you sit on it all day long, then it might press.
Shure: 可以
Shure: It can work.
Katrina: 蛮敬业的哟
Katrina: Very dedicated, huh?
Lucia:那咱每次吃饭的时候就坐在上面
Lucia: Then every time we eat, we should sit on it.
Katrina: 能长痔疮
Katrina: You'll get hemorrhoids.
Lucia:这样能让他干的就是
Lucia: This way, it'll get flatter.
Lucia:说更平一点
Lucia: Make it more even.
Lucia:只要接触空调就会缩水
Lucia: As soon as it touches the AC, it'll shrink.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈那应该不至于
Shure: Hahaha, that shouldn't happen.
Lucia:哇你的窗帘
Lucia: Wow, your curtains!
Shure: 是吧这就是充满爱意和
Shure: Right? They are filled with love and...
Katrina: 我没有爱意
Katrina: I have no love.
Lucia:这个是雨轩的吗
Lucia: Is this Rain's?
Katrina: 啊这是我的
Katrina: Ah, this is mine.
Katrina: 我买的香薰
Katrina: I bought the aroma diffuser.
Lucia:是那种蜡烛式的吗
Lucia: Is it the candle type?
Katrina: 不是无香的
Katrina: No, it's unscented.
Katrina: 他毕竟有扩扩香
Katrina: But it still spreads the fragrance.
Lucia:哦 OK
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia:好好看等你拆了记得叫我观摩一下
Lucia: It looks nice. When you open it, remember to let me take a look.
Lucia:其实我今天打开了这个盒子
Lucia: Actually, I opened this box today.
Lucia:发现里面还有一层盒子
Lucia: Found another box inside.
Lucia:你没有拆过
Lucia: You haven't opened it yet.
Lucia:我就决定先留着让你拆
Lucia: So I decided to leave it for you to open.
Katrina: 我也不知道长啥样呢
Katrina: I don't know what it looks like either.
Katrina: 万一跟那个色吸食物
Katrina: What if it's like that color food...
Lucia:啊 小心
Lucia: Ah, careful!
Jake:走看狗去
Jake: Let's go see the dog.
Jake:可以了吧
Jake: Is it okay now?
Lucia:耶
Lucia: Yay!
Lucia:i'm ready now
Lucia: I'm ready now!
Jake:狗狗
Jake: Doggy!
Lucia:哦好看
Lucia: Oh, looks good.
Jake:快去
Jake: Hurry up.
Katrina: 谁啊
Katrina: Who's that?
Jake:还有还有人呢
Jake: There's still someone here.
Jake:柯欣呢
Jake: Where's Kexin?
Katrina: 全体吗
Katrina: Everyone?
Lucia:都可以
Lucia: It's fine.
Katrina: 穿睡衣应该没问题
Katrina: Wearing pajamas should be fine.
Lucia:这是一个自由选择的副本
Lucia: It's an optional quest.
Katrina: 跟遛弯一样
Katrina: Just like going for a walk.
Jake:对就是遛弯
Jake: Yeah, it's just like a walk.
Shure: 我我我压花
Shure: I'll press the flower.
Shure: 然后一直坐着他
Shure: And then keep sitting on it.
Katrina: 行啊
Katrina: Sure.
Jake:那个能孵出糖花来
Jake: That can yield sugar flowers.
Lucia:这压花的意思其实是压在花上是吧
Lucia: Pressing flowers means pressing on the flower, right?
Katrina: 冰糖
Katrina: Rock sugar.
Shure: 纯吗这个
Shure: Is this pure?
Tasha:盐呢
Tasha: Salt?
Katrina: 盐做的
Katrina: Made with salt.
Tasha:盐呢
Tasha: Salt?
Jake:走走走咿呀走走走
Jake: Walk, walk, walk, yeah, walk, walk, walk.
Lucia:好好看
Lucia: Looks great.
Katrina: 对我要做一下我的手工任务
Katrina: Yeah, I need to do my craft task.
Katrina: 火很重的
Katrina: The fire is strong.
Shure: 我怎怎么怎么弄
Shure: How do I do it?
Shure: 下一步老师老师
Shure: What's the next step, teacher, teacher?
Katrina: 等一下老师忙副线任务去了
Katrina: Wait a second, the teacher is busy with a side quest.
Katrina: 你可以告诉我怎么做
Katrina: You can tell me how to do it.
Shure: 然后我自己弄
Shure: Then I'll do it myself.
Tasha:昨天用盐了吗
Tasha: Did you use salt yesterday?
Katrina: 我也不太知道
Katrina: I'm not really sure.
Tasha:昨天用盐了吗
Tasha: Did you use salt yesterday?
Lucia:香
Lucia: Smells good.
Shure: 昨天好像没怎么用盐
Shure: I don't think we used much salt yesterday.
Tasha:盐呢
Tasha: Salt?
Shure: 哦如果我想把它压成花的样
Shure: Oh, if I want to press it into a flower shape.
Shure: 我要让他屁股冲上是吗
Shure: I need to press its bottom up, right?
Shure: 嗯然后他的屁股冲上
Shure: Yeah, then its bottom up.
Lucia:渴了
Lucia: Thirsty.
Katrina: 然后这种的话我看人家都是侧着压的
Katrina: Then, I see people pressing it sideways.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Tasha:盐
Tasha: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina: 随便你自己发挥吧
Jake:盐什么盐
Jake: Salt? What salt?
Lucia:好看
Lucia: Looks good.
Tasha:盐
Tasha: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Katrina: 盐
Katrina: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Shure: OK那就这样
Shure: OK, let's go with that.
Lucia:盐
Lucia: Salt.
Jake:没盐了
Jake: No more salt.
Tasha:盐
Jake:我能这么能吃
Jake: How can I eat so much?
Tasha:不可能呀
Tasha: That's impossible.
Lucia:没桃了还有可能没盐应该不至于吧
Lucia: Running out of peaches is one thing, but salt? No way.
Shure: 再加一层
Shure: Add another layer.
Tasha:盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Katrina: 直接给他上两层干燥吧
Katrina: Just give him two layers of dry.
Katrina: 感觉这个有点难度呀
Katrina: This seems a bit tricky.
Jake:能在哪呢
Jake: Where could it be?
Tasha:呃
Tasha: Uh...
Tasha:不知道
Jake:应该都在这吧
Jake: It should all be here, right?
Lucia:是不是昨天烧烤的时候拿出去用过
Lucia: Did we take it out for the BBQ yesterday?
Lucia:但是那也应该拿回来了吧
Lucia: But we should've brought it back, right?
Tasha:谁把盐给偷走了
Tasha: Who took the salt?
Lucia:我们有勺了
Lucia: We have spoons now.
Jake:对买勺了
Jake: Yeah, we bought spoons.
Jake:盐没盐了怎么办
Jake: What do we do if there's no salt?
Lucia:我先在这组装
Lucia: I'll start assembling here.
Lucia:一会出发了叫我
Lucia: Call me when we leave.
Lucia:说明书上哪了在这
Lucia: Where's the manual? Oh, here it is.
Lucia:啊这玩意装完了我还得给他
Lucia: Ugh, once I finish this, I'll have to take it apart again.
Lucia:到时候再拆一次
Lucia: I'll have to dismantle it again later.
Lucia:真麻烦
Lucia: So annoying.
Lucia:咕咕咕咕咕
Lucia: Gurgle, gurgle, gurgle.
Lucia:我用一下底下这个东西
Lucia: Let me use this thing underneath.
Lucia:继续安它
Lucia: Keep installing it.
Katrina: 喂
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina: 嗯你哪位
Katrina: Hmm, who are you?
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Tasha:不要了
Tasha: No more.
Shure: 谁
Shure: Who?
Katrina: 美团
Katrina: Meituan.
Jake:盐在这
Jake: The salt is here.
Katrina: 我不知道他说什么
Katrina: I don't know what he said.
Katrina: 社区客服他问我方不方便
Katrina: The community service asked if I was available.
Shure: 那就是AI的
Shure: That's AI.
Katrina: 我说不方便
Katrina: I said I'm not available.
Katrina: 我刚看教程说这上面还要粘一层
Katrina: I just saw the tutorial, it says you need to stick another layer on top.
Tasha:看狗半个小时
Tasha: Watch the dog for half an hour.
Jake:好半小时绰绰有余
Jake: Okay, half an hour is more than enough.
Tasha:10分钟
Tasha: Ten minutes.
Jake:多久啊一般
Jake: How long usually?
Katrina: 要搞两层卧槽上午做错了
Katrina: It needs two layers, damn it, I did it wrong this morning.
Jake:狗能看个10分钟吗
Jake: Can the dog be watched for ten minutes?
Katrina: 上午忘加另一层
Katrina: I forgot to add another layer this morning.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:走吧出发
Jake: Come on, let's go.
Tasha:你不去是吗
Tasha: You're not going, right?
Shure: 我不去
Shure: I'm not going.
Tasha:你能在4:32的时候把火给关掉吗
Tasha: Can you turn off the fire at 4:32?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 定个闹钟
Katrina: Set an alarm.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 帮我定个4:32闹钟
Shure: Set an alarm for 4:32 for me.
Lucia:哎准备走了好吧
Lucia: Hey, ready to go?
Jake:走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Lucia:等我回来再接着安它
Lucia: I'll continue with it when I get back.
Lucia:呃呃you can get here and
Lucia: Uh, uh, you can get here and...
Lucia:哎这对吗 1 2
Lucia: Hey, is this right? 1, 2...
Jake:哎今天天适合出去玩
Jake: Hey, the weather is perfect for going out today.
Jake:是吧 2
Jake: Right? 2...
Lucia:我怎么觉得还有一个2
Lucia: Why do I feel there's another 2?
Lucia:不管了先这样吧
Lucia: Never mind, let's leave it for now.
Lucia:这扣上吗
Lucia: Should I fasten this?
Jake:不用扣上
Jake: No need to fasten it.
Jake:没关系的我
Jake: It's okay, I...
Lucia:不好意思你回答晚了
Lucia: Sorry, you answered too late.
Jake:赛博小队
Jake: Cyber squad.
Jake:慧欣你带充电器了没
Jake: Huixin, did you bring the charger?
Alice:带了
Alice: Brought it.
Jake:好的强 牛逼
Jake: Great, awesome.
Jake:你有吗
Jake: Do you have one?
Jake:你没有
Jake: You don't have one?
Lucia:我当然有了
Lucia: Of course I have one.
Jake:哎 猫
Jake: Hey, a cat.
Lucia:嗯哪里哪里
Lucia: Hmm, where, where?
Lucia:噢看见了
Lucia: Oh, I see it.
Jake:想割
Jake: Wanna cut it?
Jake:这是韭菜吗
Jake: Is this chives?
Lucia:不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia:我以为这是大葱因为上面有头
Lucia: I thought it was scallion because it has a bulb.
Lucia:就是葱花
Lucia: It's scallion.
Jake:每个人都有不同的解读
Jake: Everyone has different interpretations.
Lucia:这话五谷不分呢
Lucia: That's being ignorant about grains.
Tasha:说明四体不轻
Tasha: It means they're physically weak.
Lucia:好香哦
Lucia: It smells so good.
Tasha:丁香吧
Tasha: It's clove.
Lucia:拔一搓去做压花
Lucia: Pull a handful and press them into flowers.
Jake:好啊
Jake: Sure.
Jake:拔 拔一点可以
Jake: Pull, pull a bit, it's fine.
Tasha:啊好香呀
Tasha: Ah, it smells so good.
Lucia:哇好好看呀
Lucia: Wow, it's so pretty.
Lucia:拔一个
Lucia: Pull one.
Lucia:回来路上再拔
Lucia: Pull more on the way back.
Jake:等等等等等等
Jake: Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Alice:都都麻得
Alice: Everything's numb.
Lucia:好香
Lucia: It smells good.
Lucia:嘻嘻
Lucia: Hehe.
Tasha:这家也种这个呀
Tasha: This house also grows these?
Tasha:这紫藤萝
Tasha: This wisteria.
Jake:长得跟葡萄似的
Jake: Looks like grapes.
Tasha:行那你吃一个
Tasha: Fine, then eat one.
Lucia:给
Lucia: Here.
Jake:哈哈哈不太圆
Jake: Haha, not quite round.
Jake:我已经准备好了
Jake: I'm ready.
Lucia:给您准备好了
Lucia: Got it ready for you.
Jake:不太圆这葡萄啊
Jake: These grapes aren't quite round.
Tasha:这么快
Tasha: So quick.
Jake:一个老朋友
Jake: An old friend.
Jake:哦谢谢你
Jake: Oh, thank you.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia:噫
Lucia: Eww.
小狗老板:叫卡布
Dog Owner: It's called Kabu.
Jake:哎赛博小队
Jake: Hey, cyber team.
Jake:现在观摩
Jake: Watching now.
Lucia: 好可爱
Lucia: So cute.
Lucia: 嘴巴一直在咬
Lucia: Its mouth keeps biting.
小狗老板：它爱咬这种它喜欢这种托鞋
Dog Owner: It loves biting this kind, it likes this slipper.
小狗老板:我儿子的感应
Dog Owner: My son's feeling.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 好多人他都闻不过来了
Lucia: There are so many people, he can't smell them all.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:他有名字吗
Jake: Does he have a name?
Tasha: 卡布
Tasha: Kabu.
邻居:听说是卡布
Neighbor: I heard it's Kabu.
Jake:卡布
Jake: Kabu.
Jake:这颜色确实
Jake: The color really is...
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:啊给抹小肚子了
Alice: Ah, rubbing his little belly.
Lucia:好可爱
Lucia: So cute.
邻居:小屋子养的猫
Neighbor: A cat raised in a small house.
邻居:然后冬天看猫冻死了
Neighbor: Then in winter, saw the cat frozen to death.
邻居:都在家里都是11只
Neighbor: All at home, there are 11 of them.
邻居:你忘了没有
Neighbor: Did you forget?
邻居:还没忘啊
Neighbor: Haven't forgotten yet?
Alice:啊小狗味
Alice: Ah, the puppy smell.
Alice:臭臭的香死了
Alice: Stinky but smells nice.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: Hahaha, brilliant!
小狗老板:它咬你你走开还小
Dog Owner: If it bites you, just walk away, it's still small.
小狗老板:长牙长牙
Dog Owner: Teething, teething.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
小狗老板:它老想啃东西
Dog Owner: It always wants to gnaw on things.
Alice:小狗味 可爱吧你说
Alice: Puppy smell. Cute, right?
小狗老板：它才洗了两三天澡就搁这打滚成这样了
Dog Owner: It just had a bath two or three days ago and now it's rolling around like this.
Nicous: 这小狗多久洗一次呀
Nicous: How often does this puppy get a bath?
小狗老板:我们刚拿 回来它不让洗
Dog Owner: We just got it, it didn't allow us to bathe it.
Jake:呵呵确实爱咬人
Jake: Haha, it really loves to bite people.
Jake:确实爱咬人
Jake: It really loves to bite people.
Lucia:它 哇
Lucia: It... wow.
Jake:咬你了吧
Jake: It bit you, right?
Lucia: 突然舔一口
Lucia: Suddenly licked me.
Jake:舔噢
Jake: It licked you?
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:他为什么尽咬我
Jake: Why does it keep biting me?
Lucia: 你看起来像磨牙棒
Lucia: You look like a chew toy.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:对有很多摄像头
Jake: Yes, there are many cameras.
Jake:这我们在做研究的时候
Jake: When we are doing research,
小狗老板:哦 科技产品
Puppy Boss: Oh, tech products.
Jake:科技产品
Jake: Tech products.
Jake:就是我们在这转一圈
Jake: We just make a round here,
Jake:你们这房子就 重现出来了
Jake: and your house will be recreated.
小狗老板:被你们拍摄下来了
Puppy Boss: Filmed by you guys.
Jake:就是重现 就是有一个3D模型对
Jake: Recreated, with a 3D model, yes.
小狗老板:建模
Puppy Boss: Modeling.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:然后这狗
Jake: And this dog,
Jake:如果不动的话也可以把它建出来
Jake: if it doesn't move, we can model it too.
Jake:但是现在没办法
Jake: But now, we can't.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:这不能咬
Lucia: Don't bite this.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:线不能咬
Lucia: Don't bite the wire.
Lucia:别的地方你都可以咬
Lucia: You can bite other things.
Jake:对线不能咬
Jake: Right, don't bite the wire.
Jake:哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Jake:现在我们还差根管
Jake: Now we still need a tube.
Jake:每人插管
Jake: Each person needs a tube.
小狗老板:这是科技新
Puppy Boss: This is new tech.
Jake:这这还不是产品
Jake: This is not a product yet.
Jake:这没有量产
Jake: It's not mass-produced.
Jake:还买不着
Jake: You can't buy it yet.
Lucia:实验阶段
Lucia: Experimental stage.
小狗老板:那你们这是一家什么公司
Puppy Boss: So, what kind of company is this?
Jake:呃是算学校学校的研究
Jake: Uh, it's a research project from a school.
小狗老板:学校的
Puppy Boss: From a school?
Jake:学校 对
Jake: Yes, a school.
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:然后这产品是那个
Jake: And this product is for...
Jake:叫什么脸书脸书脸书Face book mate
Jake: What do you call it? Facebook, Facebook, Facebook mate.
Lucia:小可爱
Lucia: Cutie.
Jake:就
Jake: Just...
Jake:就是一个8000美元
Jake: It's like $8000.
小狗老板:妈呀
Dog Boss: Oh my god.
小狗老板:这一会我这院子里就值钱了
Dog Boss: My yard's gonna be worth a lot soon.
小狗老板:那你们这什么学校
Dog Boss: So, what school are you from?
Jake:我们来至不同的学校
Jake: We come from different schools.
Jake:但是这个实验室是这个南亚理工的
Jake: But this lab is from South Asia Tech.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:新加坡 我从新加坡过来的
Jake: Singapore. I came from Singapore.
小狗老板:我一个大学同学他在去南亚理工读过书然后
Dog Boss: I had a college classmate who went to South Asia Tech to study.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:他还知道跑过去
Jake: He knew to go there.
Jake:哦哪个学校
Jake: Oh, which school?
小狗老板:我是
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
小狗老板:然后他是在三亚上完学之后
Dog Boss: He finished school in Sanya.
小狗老板:好像先去的我那个
Dog Boss: Then he went to...
小狗老板:宿舍同学先去的
Dog Boss: My dorm mate went first.
小狗老板:人大读研在去的
Dog Boss: Then he went to Renmin University for grad school.
小狗老板:南亚理工读的那个博士
Dog Boss: And then South Asia Tech for his PhD.
Jake:噢 OK OK  校友啊
Jake: Oh, okay, okay. Fellow alumni!
Jake:为什么跑这么远
Jake: Why did he go so far?
Jake:他为啥跑这么远
Alice:阿布
Alice: Abu.
Jake:我
Jake: I...
Nicous: 旺旺旺
Nicous: Woof woof woof.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah!
Alice:拉粑粑
Alice: Poop.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:他应该是在哪拿的
Jake: Where did he get it?
Jake:也没地
Jake: There's no place.
Lucia:卡布
Lucia: Kabu.
Jake:是他在叫吗
Jake: Is he the one calling?
Alice:小狗尖叫
Alice: The dog is screaming.
Alice:卡布 过来
Alice: Kabu, come here.
Lucia:哎哟 妈呀
Lucia: Oh my god.
Lucia:凳子好矮
Lucia: The chair is so low.
Alice:狗狗碎碎
Alice: The dog is shattered.
Tasha:哈哈 强行坐下
Tasha: Haha, forcefully sitting down.
Alice:摇头晃脑的
Alice: Shaking its head.
Alice:它想咬东西
Alice: It wants to bite something.
Jake:他这衣服是干嘛的
Jake: What's with this outfit?
Jake:能被提起来吗
Jake: Can it be lifted?
Alice:溜的吧
Alice: For walking, I guess.
Jake:哦溜的是吧
Jake: Oh, it's for walking?
Alice:狗绳
Alice: A leash.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:单手拎
Jake: Lift with one hand.
Jake:塑料袋
Jake: Like a plastic bag.
Jake:唉我去 这是边牧吧
Jake: Wow, is this a Border Collie?
Alice:你管掉了
Alice: You dropped it.
Nicous: 它拉粑粑了
Nicous: It pooped.
Alice:门口
Alice: At the door.
小狗老板:你可真会拉
Puppy Boss: You really know how to poop.
Nicous: 该打
Nicous: Needs a spanking.
小狗老板:讨厌
Puppy Boss: Annoying.
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:哎哟
Jake: Ouch.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia:嗯嗯嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Jake:教训教训
Jake: Teach it a lesson.
Jake:挨教训了
Jake: It got taught a lesson.
Lucia:缩起来了
Lucia: It curled up.
Jake:挨打了
Jake: It got hit.
Nicous: 还咬 又 又要挨一拳
Nicous: It's biting again, another punch coming.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:打了吗
Jake: Did it get hit?
Lucia:他打疫苗了吧
Lucia: Did it get vaccinated?
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia:那他刚在我手上咬了一下
Lucia: It just bit my hand.
小狗老板:没事没事
Puppy Boss: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:居然没烂
Lucia: It didn't even tear.
Nicous: 没烂没事
Nicous: It didn't tear, it's fine.
小狗老板:哦没出血不
Puppy Boss: Oh, it didn't bleed?
Lucia:没有就是稍薇这样刮了一下
Lucia: No, it just scratched a little.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
小狗老板:哦犬舍说它打过了
Puppy Boss: The kennel said it got vaccinated.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia:我有必要现在去打个疫苗吗
Lucia: Do I need to get a vaccine now?
Lucia:应该没破的时候
Lucia: It shouldn't be broken
Jake:应该没事没事
Jake: It should be fine, no worries
小狗老板:啊这也没事
Nicous: Ah, it's fine
Jake:没事没事
Jake: No worries, no worries
Lucia:啊那就行
Lucia: Ah, that's good then
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
小狗老板:别让它咬着
Nicous: Don't let it bite
小狗老板:它打是打了我们就是怕犬舍没打好
Nicous: It's vaccinated, but we're just worried the kennel didn't do it properly
小狗老板:回头在给它重新打一遍
Nicous: We'll get it vaccinated again later
Alice:小弱电 梅花
Alice: Weak electricity, plum blossom
Alice:嗨
Alice: Hi
小狗老板:我得接娃去
Nicous: I need to pick up the kids
Jake:嚯 这么能咬
Jake: Whoa, it bites so hard
Jake:我去 直接咬下去了
Jake: Oh my, it bit right through
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn
Tasha:我靠
Tasha: Jeez
Jake:好吃吗
Jake: Is it tasty?
Alice:卡布 卡布
Alice: Carbo, Carbo
小狗老板:接哥哥去了晚上来接你哈
Nicous: Going to pick up my brother, I'll pick you up tonight
小狗老板:走了 再见 拜拜
Nicous: I'm off, see you, bye
小狗老板:小布一会给它关笼子啊
Nicous: Little Boo, lock it in the cage later
Alice:走路都不敢露出来怕它咬
Alice: I don't even dare to show my feet when walking, afraid it might bite
小狗老板:咬托鞋
Nicous: Biting slippers
Jake:喜欢托鞋
Jake: Loves slippers
小狗老板:它现在是长牙要换牙那个阶段
Nicous: It's in the teething stage right now
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
小狗老板:然后它就是所以就是拿牙去衡量去体会
Nicous: So it uses its teeth to measure and experience things
Alice:牙咬
Alice: Biting teeth
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh
Alice:啃完左右啃又脚
Alice: Gnaws everything, even my feet
Jake:当手用
Jake: Uses its teeth like hands
小狗老板:昨晚上回家吃了点饭9点半
Nicous: Last night I went home, had some food around 9:30
Jake:咬石头
Jake: Biting stones
小狗老板:我去看看窝里头
Nicous: I went to check on the nest
小狗老板:看了之后12点多了
Nicous: After checking, it was already past midnight
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh my
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha:皮
Tasha: Naughty
Jake:呃你你你们没有脸
Jake: Uh, you, you guys don't have faces
Jake:就是你们会被打码
Jake: I mean, you'll be blurred out
Jake:对 放心
Jake: Yes, don't worry
Jake:所有的人包括我们也没有脸
Jake: Everyone, including us, won't have faces
小狗老板:就是打马赛克是吧
Nicous: You mean, like pixelated, right?
Alice:来玩呗小狗
Alice: Come play, Nicous
Alice:小狗
Alice: Nicous
小狗老板:兄弟几 呃 04年的 啊
Nicous: Bro, um, from 2004, right?
路人：04年
Bystander: 2004
小狗老板:04年的
Nicous: 2004
路人：对
Bystander: Yes
Alice:啊它露肚皮了
Alice: Ah, it's showing its belly
Jake:哎 它还有一个画像
Jake: Hey, it even has a portrait
Jake:唉 我去
Jake: Oh my
Jake:有点想提它 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Kind of want to pick it up, hahaha
Jake:是没提起来啊
Jake: Couldn't lift it, huh
Tasha:哎哟
Tasha: Oh dear
Jake:哎哟我去不给提
Jake: Oh my, it won't let me lift it
Jake:回去回去
Jake: Go back, go back
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no
Alice:过来
Alice: Come here
Alice:过来 咬鞋子
Alice: Come here, bite the shoe
Alice:给
Alice: Here
Alice:干啥
Alice: What are you doing?
Alice:脚很大
Alice: Big feet
Jake:它刚刚摔着了吗
Jake: Did it just fall?
Alice:脚很厚实
Alice: Thick feet
Jake:嚯 它又找那个啥玩意
Jake: Whoa, it's looking for that thing again
Alice:给这死缠
Alice: Here, this clingy one
Jake:把你提起来
Jake: Let's lift you up
Jake:哎  不行不行不行这个不行 这个不行
Jake: No, no, no, this won't do, this won't do
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah
Alice:给提起来啦
Alice: It's lifted up
Jake:完了 互换攻击了
Jake: Done, mutual attack
Jake:想那么逗猫你逗它
Jake: If you want to tease the cat, tease it
Alice:呀 呀 呀
Alice: Ah, ah, ah
Jake:哎哟
Jake: Oh my
Alice:呀 吓死我啦
Alice: Ah, you scared me
Nicous: 我草
小狗老板:你94年是吧
Puppy Boss: You were born in '94, right?
小狗老板:04年
Puppy Boss: No, '04.
小狗老板:村里头流浪的小动物好多吧
Puppy Boss: There are a lot of stray animals in the village, right?
Jake:嗯 是
Jake: Yeah, there are.
小狗老板:那个好多好多猫
Puppy Boss: There are so many cats.
小狗老板:然后这个这个程序里面就是流浪的猫
Puppy Boss: And in this program, it's all about stray cats.
小狗老板:就是看到过先罗
Puppy Boss: Like, have you seen those?
小狗老板:看见过好多名贵的品种
Puppy Boss: I've seen many exotic breeds.
Nicous: 先罗 布偶
Nicous: Exotic breeds, Ragdolls.
小狗老板:啊对 都有 啊对
Puppy Boss: Yeah, exactly, all kinds.
小狗老板:里面都有各种名犬名猫
Puppy Boss: There are all sorts of famous dogs and cats.
Jake:这么有意思 为啥在这
Jake: That's interesting, why are they here?
Tasha:为啥流浪了呀
Tasha: Why are they strays?
小狗老板:不知道全跑那屋里
Puppy Boss: No idea, they all ran inside.
Nicous: 你说收了多少只猫
Nicous: How many cats have you taken in?
Jake:上哪去了
Jake: Where did they go?
小狗老板:本来有好多只
Puppy Boss: There were so many initially.
小狗老板:结果看来不行他们的脾气不好
Puppy Boss: But it seems they didn't get along, their temperaments were bad.
小狗老板:一个有一个马桶
Puppy Boss: One even had a toilet.
小狗老板:我家有四个还是六个忘了
小狗老板:最多是六个马桶 就是一人一个
小狗老板:它不在这里面尿 它就去别的地方尿
Alice:领地
小狗老板:它的占地意识特别强
Jake:是
小狗老板:这只猫啊和我一个马桶
小狗老板:每天尿到哪里都是
小狗老板:后来实在受不了了
Jake:它这是要干你了它这个
Jake:这个姿势
Alice:我也没惹你呀 你把我鞋咬成这样了
Alice:我都没在乎呢
Alice:咬吧咬吧
Jake:干哈你干哈
Jake:看地瓜去吧
Jake: Let's go check out the sweet potatoes.
Tasha:这么害怕
Tasha: So scared.
Alice:很乖呀
Alice: So well-behaved.
Nicous: 哦呀 被发现了
Nicous: Oh no, got caught.
Alice:是不是血统比较纯的那种
Alice: Is it a purebred one?
Alice:因为它爪子得很肥很厚实
Alice: Because its paws are very fat and thick.
Jake:这这怎么看这很容易看吗
Jake: How do you see that? Is it easy to tell?
Alice:就看它的爪子
Alice: Just look at its paws.
Jake:哈这么讲究
Jake: Wow, that's pretty detailed.
邻居:它还挺亲人
Neighbor: It's quite friendly.
邻居:你啥名
Neighbor: What's its name?
邻居:卡布 我们家有一只大秋田
Neighbor: Kabu. We have a big Akita at home.
邻居:长大了这可拆家了
Neighbor: When it grows up, it can really tear the house apart.
邻居:真的 它精力太旺盛了
Neighbor: Really, it's super energetic.
Alice:它挺乖的
Alice: It's quite obedient.
Jake:见啥都咬
Jake: It bites everything it sees.
小狗老板:喜欢咬线磨牙呢
Puppy Owner: It likes to chew on wires to grind its teeth.
小狗老板:喜欢玩那种装修的
Puppy Owner: It likes to play with those renovation materials.
Jake:过来过去那种拉货的货车
Jake: Like those delivery trucks going back and forth.
邻居:哦你的牙齿还挺锋
Neighbor: Oh, its teeth are pretty sharp.
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
邻居:嘿嘿这衣服不能咬
Neighbor: Hey, hey, you can't bite this clothes.
邻居:它真是在磨牙 见啥都咬
Neighbor: It's really teething, it bites everything it sees.
Jake:头垂
Jake: Head down.
邻居:它长大了其实也挺好看
Neighbor: When it grows up, it actually looks quite good.
邻居:其实我觉得狗这么小的时候挺好玩的
Neighbor: Actually, I think dogs are really fun when they're this small.
邻居:好看
Neighbor: Cute.
邻居:这是几个月啊这个狗
Neighbor: How old is this dog?
小狗老板:啊
Puppy Owner: Huh?
邻居:这几个月手上这个
Neighbor: How many months is it?
小狗老板:才2个月
Puppy Owner: Only 2 months.
邻居:两个月挺好的
Neighbor: Two months, that's good.
小狗老板:不小了这个个挺大
Puppy Owner: It's not small, it's pretty big.
邻居:长大有比秋天
Neighbor: Will it grow bigger than an Akita?
小狗老板:小
Puppy Owner: No, smaller.
邻居:小点
Neighbor: Smaller.
小狗老板:对它不是小型犬
Puppy Owner: Yeah, it's not a small breed.
Nicous: 它是中型犬
Nicous: It's a medium breed.
邻居:中型犬
Neighbor: Medium breed.
小狗老板:有 不是 边牧有这么大
Puppy Owner: Yeah, Border Collies can grow this big.
小狗老板:然后还有长这么大
Puppy Owner: And they can grow even bigger.
小狗老板:有不一样的有这么大的
Puppy Owner: There are different sizes, this big.
小狗老板:高度长度这么高
Puppy Owner: Height, length, this tall.
小狗老板:对对对这是属于小型犬
Puppy Owner: Yeah, this is considered a small breed.
小狗老板:然后边牧属于大型犬
Puppy Owner: And Border Collies are considered large breeds.
小狗老板:边牧都很大的
Nicous: Border Collies are all pretty big.
邻居:哦 它 它 就是
Neighbor: Oh, it, it is...
邻居:狗界它就是排名第一的这个狗
Neighbor: Among dogs, it's ranked number one.
Jake:比我熟练多了
Jake: Much more skilled than me.
邻居:卡布
Neighbor: Cabo.
邻居:现在叫它知道是在叫它
Neighbor: Now it knows you're calling it.
邻居:还没长大
Neighbor: Still hasn't grown up.
小狗老板:对它现在还不是很清楚
Nicous: Yeah, it's still not really sure.
邻居:可以送去学校去那种
Neighbor: You can send it to school.
邻居:我们家那个狗
Neighbor: Our dog...
邻居:我没有养狗的经验
Neighbor: I have no experience raising dogs.
邻居:它就在长就长到那个
Neighbor: It just grew and grew until...
邻居:五六个朋的时候
Neighbor: It was five or six months old.
邻居:很淘特别淘
Neighbor: Very naughty, extremely naughty.
邻居:拉屎拉到满屋都是
Neighbor: Pooped all over the house.
邻居:把我衣服全部胡了
Neighbor: Ruined all my clothes.
邻居:就给它送学校送了半年
Neighbor: So we sent it to school for half a year.
邻居:就学会了在外面上厕所
Neighbor: It learned to use the bathroom outside.
邻居:坐立 握手
Neighbor: Sit, stay, shake hands.
邻居:因为在家我也关注它
Neighbor: Because at home I also paid attention to it.
邻居:现在长大了也挺乖的
Neighbor: Now that it's grown up, it's pretty well-behaved.
Jake:还得上学
Jake: It still needs to go to school.
邻居:上学狗上学很贵咧
Neighbor: Dog school is very expensive.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:跟我玩会吧 来
Alice: Play with me for a bit, come on.
小狗老板:小狗
Nicous: Puppy.
Alice:小狗
Alice: Puppy.
Jake:走吧 要不
Jake: Let's go, shall we?
Tasha:好 还是金毛粘人
Tasha: Okay, golden retrievers are still the clingiest.
Nicous: 现在去哪里
Nicous: Where are we going now?
Jake:还能去哪里了
Jake: Where else can we go?
Alice:拜拜
Alice: Bye-bye.
Lucia:是真花吗
Lucia: Is it a real flower?
Tasha:好像是唉
Tasha: I think so.
Lucia:是真花
Lucia: It's a real flower.
Lucia:香槟玫瑰
Lucia: Champagne rose.
小狗老板：你们是住在市区
Nicous: Do you guys live in the city?
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Nicous: 那边那个绿色的她说
Nicous: That green one over there, she said.
小狗老板：另外一个院子
Nicous: The other courtyard.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh
Jake:啥
Jake: What?
Nicous: 他说他之前在我们那个民宿干
Nicous: He said he used to work at our homestay.
Tasha:哦哈
Tasha: Oh, really?
Jake:还有附近还有啥啊
Jake: What else is around here?
Nicous: 没了
Nicous: Nothing.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:烤地瓜去吧
Jake: Let's go roast some sweet potatoes.
Lucia:哪啊
Lucia: Where?
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:哈 烤地瓜
Jake: Haha, roast sweet potatoes.
Jake:她整了点地瓜
Jake: She got some sweet potatoes.
Nicous: 是挖的吗
Nicous: Did she dig them up?
Alice:买的
Alice: Bought them.
Jake:挖的挖的
Jake: Dug them up, dug them up.
Tasha:地里现挖的
Tasha: Freshly dug from the field.
Alice:现种的
Alice: Freshly planted.
Nicous: 我不信你挖的玩个金铲铲都
Nicous: I don't believe you dug them up, you were just playing with a golden shovel.
Nicous: 都 都骗我
Nicous: All, all lies.
Tasha:我没有骗你
Tasha: I didn't lie to you.
Nicous: 信不了啦
Nicous: Can't believe it.
Tasha:你还骗 我呢
Tasha: You lied to me too.
Nicous: 我哪骗你了
Nicous: When did I lie to you?
Tasha:指挥我把乌迪尔全卖产了
Tasha: You told me to sell all my Udyr cards.
Nicous: 那我这不是有意的
Nicous: That wasn't on purpose.
Alice:回去吗
Alice: Going back?
Jake:还是在踩踩风
Jake: Or just wandering around.
Jake:兜一圈
Jake: Take a loop.
Jake:好像也没什么
Jake: Seems like there's nothing much.
Lucia:哎呀 妈
Lucia: Oh my god.
Jake:北京是个
Jake: Beijing is a...
Lucia:直辖市
Lucia: Municipality.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈啊哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha, why is it so high?
Jake: 为为什么有这么高啊
Jake: Why is it so high?
Jake:给一张照片北京这里是什么
Jake: Give a photo of Beijing, what is this place?
Jake: 然后AI回答是个城市就这个
Jake: And AI answers it's a city, just like that.
Jake: AI就不过审是不是
Jake: AI wouldn't pass, right?
Jake: AI就是没有过测试
Jake: AI just failed the test.
Lucia:而且说一定要瞧开
Lucia: And it insisted on being correct.
Jake:傻眼
Jake: Dumbfounded.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 这个经典QA啊
Jake: This is a classic QA.
Jake: 这个是经典VQA
Jake: This is classic VQA.
Lucia: 什么给个照片问这是什么
Lucia: What, like give a photo and ask what it is?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 然后回答的问题
Jake: Then answer the question.
Jake: 和图片一点关系都没有了
Jake: And the answer has nothing to do with the picture.
Jake: 很标准的
Jake: It's very standard.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 啊对是的
Jake: Oh yes, exactly.
Jake: 我之前就上个月
Jake: Last month
Jake: 和东京大学一帮人做的
Jake: I did this with a group from Tokyo University.
Jake: 就是做这个网友
Jake: We were working on this project.
Lucia: 那你们最后成果怎么样了
Lucia: So how did your results turn out?
Lucia:他是RTF说你猜来着
Lucia: Was it RTF or something, you guess?
Lucia:还是RTV说一点哦
Lucia: Or was it RTV, just a bit?
Jake: 就我们就测了一遍哦OK
Jake: We just tested once, okay.
Jake: 对然后大多数都是一点
Jake: Yeah, and most of it was just a bit.
Lucia: 大多数都是一点
Lucia: Most of it was just a bit.
Jake: 结论就是这样
Jake: That's the conclusion.
Jake: 哈哈哈确实对
Jake: Hahaha, indeed.
Lucia: 所以你们最初的假设是什么呢
Lucia: So what was your initial hypothesis?
Jake: 我们就是就假设
Jake: We were just hypothesizing.
Jake: 因为我们稍微试了试
Jake: Because we tried a bit.
Lucia:假设
Lucia: Hypothesizing.
Jake: 就是很多这种图哦
Jake: That there were a lot of these pictures.
Jake: 就给问给他了很多这种QA他都做不好
Jake: And gave them a lot of these QAs, and they couldn't do well.
Lucia:ok
Lucia: Okay.
Jake: 然后大概就
Jake: And then roughly...
Jake: 所以你们根据结论修改了自己的假设
Jake: So did you revise your hypothesis based on the conclusion?
假设是吧
Lucia: The hypothesis, right?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 就是这就这这这就是一个单纯的测试
Jake: This was just a pure test.
Jake: 这没有假设就是他是什么样
Jake: There was no hypothesis, it was just what it was.
Lucia:哦 ok ok
Jake: 我们repot一下
Jake: We just reported it.
Lucia:啊OK OK
Lucia: Ah, okay, okay.
Lucia: 做研究
Lucia: Doing research.
Lucia: 主要学会根据结论修改自己的假设
Lucia: The main thing is to learn to revise your hypothesis based on conclusions.
Jake: 米家
Jake: Mi Home.
Jake: 你们看到过小米的车吗
Jake: Have you guys ever seen Xiaomi's car?
Jake: 实体师
Jake: In person
Nicous: 没见过
Nicous: Nope, never seen it.
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No, I haven't.
Tasha:听说在西二线才能看到
Tasha: I heard you can only see it on the Western Second Line.
Nicous: 听说小米产了一万台
Nicous: I heard Xiaomi produced ten thousand units.
Nicous: 无限台都被遭
Nicous: They all underwent
Nicous: 无限台都被各种压力测试
Nicous: They all underwent various stress tests.
Tasha:嗯 嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Nicous: 我今天才看到最离谱的在小米的前盖板上装
Nicous: Today, I saw the most outrageous thing installed on Xiaomi's front cover.
Jake:这个测试什么呀
Jake: What kind of test is that?
Lucia:哎哟 妈
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Tasha:晚上怎么安排
Tasha: What's the plan for tonight?
Jake: 对今天就是测试测就是测试
Jake: Yeah, today is all about testing, just testing.
Jake: 呃实现了一些
Jake: Uh, we've accomplished some things.
Jake: 其实大部分都实现了
Jake: Actually, most of them are achieved.
Lucia:那小部分没实现的是什么
Lucia: What about the ones we haven't achieved?
Lucia:咱争取实现一下呗
Lucia: Should we try to achieve them?
Jake: 争取实现什么
Jake: Try to achieve what?
Jake:勾芡火锅
Jake: Thickened hot pot.
Lucia:火锅已经吃过了这条PASS吧
Lucia: We've already had hot pot, let's pass on that one.
Jake:就是乱买一些
Jake: Just randomly buying stuff.
Nicous: 每一个人要去买
Nicous: Everyone needs to buy
Nicous: 很恐怖的食材但是能吃没毒
Nicous: some really scary ingredients but they're edible and non-toxic.
Nicous: 然后每个人
Nicous: And then everyone
Lucia:咱这个不准去实现
Lucia: We shouldn't try to achieve this one.
Nicous: 然后闭着眼睛夹夹到什么就吃
Nicous: Then with eyes closed, pick and eat whatever you get.
Jake: 适合抽签决定谁吃猪脑啊
Jake: Perfect for drawing lots to see who eats pig brain.
Nicous: 不是你接触得到人技术人想出来的
Nicous: This is not something you'd expect from a tech person.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Nicous: 这个原来它
Nicous: So originally
Jake:所以就不怕挨打
Jake: So, no fear of getting hit.
Nicous: 所以
Nicous: So
Nicous: 所以他想玩就扔了
Nicous: So, he just threw it away if he wanted to play.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia:嗯  啊这样啊
Lucia: Ah, I see.
Lucia: 那咱还是不用争取实现了
Lucia: Then let's not try to achieve it.
Lucia: 看来没被实现的目标都是有原因的
Lucia: Seems like there are reasons for the unachieved goals.
Lucia: 哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, yeah.
Alice:刚说的食材比如说呢
Alice: Just mentioned ingredients, like what?
Jake: 猪脑
Jake: Pig brain.
Lucia:刚想说脑花
Lucia: I was just about to say brain.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Nicous: 猪脑我特别爱吃
Nicous: I really love pig brain.
Jake: 脑我也挺喜欢吃
Jake: I like brain too.
Jake: 但是这个太油了
Jake: But it's too greasy.
Jake: 我吃一次就
Jake: I can only eat it once.
Lucia: 不行他这长相让我无法接受
Lucia: No, its appearance is unacceptable to me.
Lucia: 我是颜控
Lucia: I'm a face-judger.
Alice:羊眼算了
Alice: Sheep eyes, forget it.
Lucia: 长相也让我无法接受啊
Lucia: Its appearance is also unacceptable.
Jake: 羊眼也有
Jake: There are sheep eyes too.
Jake: 羊眼没吃过
Jake: I haven't tried sheep eyes.
Nicous: 变的
Nicous: Different.
Nicous: 各种变的
Nicous: All kinds of different.
Jake: 这能买到吗
Jake: Can you buy this?
Jake: 北京北京哦
Jake: In Beijing, Beijing.
Jake: 得菜市场买吧
Jake: Probably at a market.
Nicous: 我说实话这种东西好像东北特别火吧
Nicous: Honestly, this stuff is super popular in the northeast.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 这是贴地上
Jake: This is stuck to the ground.
Lucia: 那应该一会就找不到了吧会煮化掉
Lucia: Then it should disappear soon, it will melt when cooked.
Lucia: 是什么来着
Lucia: What was it again?
Lucia: 3
Jake:院子里是有人吗
Jake: Is someone in the yard?
Alice:顺丰快递
Alice: SF Express.
Jake: 查水表
Jake: Checking the water meter.
Lucia: 顺丰快递
Lucia: SF Express.
Shure: 请进
Shure: Come in.
Jake: 出来压了
Jake: Coming out to press.
Jake: 是在外边压的更结实吗
Jake: Is it pressed more firmly outside?
Katrina: 早上少放了一层
Katrina: Missed a layer in the morning.
Lucia:哎谁给这猫加了一个小球啊
Lucia: Hey, who added a small ball for this cat?
Alice:加小球
Alice: Added a small ball.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 我本来是看到这个动作我就画了一个
Lucia: I drew one when I saw this action.
Lucia: 这只猫
Lucia: This cat.
Alice:有人吗
Alice: Is anyone there?
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 你洗手吗
Lucia: Are you washing your hands?
Lucia: 那我在门口等着你洗完好了
Lucia: Then I'll wait for you at the door until you're done.
Jake: 今天薄荷叶干啥呀
Jake: What are we doing with mint leaves today?
Tasha:薄荷叶哦
Tasha: Mint leaves, huh.
Tasha:到了
Tasha: We're here.
Jake:到了在哪呢
Jake: Where are we exactly?
Jake: 今天做什么呀师傅
Jake: What are we making today, chef?
Tasha:都可以呀想吃什么就做什么
Tasha: Anything you like, just make whatever you want.
Jake: 那您这是干嘛的呀
Jake: So what are you doing?
Tasha:烤地瓜
Tasha: Roasting sweet potatoes.
Jake: 就单烤地瓜
Jake: Just roasting sweet potatoes?
Lucia: 我们是在外面烤
Lucia: We're roasting outside.
Lucia: 那那个烤
Lucia: So that roast...
Lucia: 烤箱上不是烤肉炉上烤吗
Lucia: Isn't the roast supposed to be done in the oven, not the grill?
Jake:嗯咱没炭炭咱就不
Jake: Well, we don't have any charcoal, so we can't...
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia:那还是烤箱烤吧
Lucia: Then let's use the oven.
Lucia: 给自己降低一点难度
Lucia: Make it a bit easier for ourselves.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 这个钟好好看啊
Lucia: This clock is really nice.
Jake:哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 有一种非常简约的美感
Lucia: It has a very minimalist beauty.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake: 还要大一点更好看
Jake: It would look even better if it were bigger.
Lucia: 确实但是这个也可以
Lucia: True, but this size is good too.
Lucia: 就是它可以无缝融入各种
Lucia: It can seamlessly blend into various...
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia:装饰
Lucia: Decorations.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Lucia: and if you came to see
Lucia: And if you came to see...
Lucia:我们不卡哦K吗
Lucia: We're not lagging, okay?
Lucia:我说的不是PPT卡
Lucia: I'm not talking about PPT lag.
Lucia:呵呵
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:我还没安完
Lucia: I haven't finished setting it up yet.
Lucia: 我一会就
Lucia: I'll be done soon.
Lucia: 今天晚上的活动是组装柜子
Lucia: Tonight's activity is assembling the cabinet.
Lucia:what is 啊OK
Lucia: What is "Ah, OK"?
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 嗯受不了
Katrina: Hmm, can't stand it.
Katrina: 因为我觉得
Katrina: Because I think
Katrina: 如果你没有一个结果的话
Katrina: If you don't have a conclusion
Katrina:  要么就断要么就
Katrina: You either end it or
Katrina:  如果你没有一个
Katrina: If you don't have a
Lucia:唉
Lucia: Hey
Lucia:哎哟
Lucia: Oh no
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh man
Jake: 有电吗你们 嚯
Jake: Do you have power? Whoa
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Haha
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No
Shure: 都没有
Shure: None of us do
Jake: 你们两位都没有
Jake: Neither of you?
Shure: 那应该
Shure: That should
Jake: sorry应该没那么快就满了
Jake: Sorry, it shouldn't be full so soon
Jake: 你是哦
Jake: Are you, uh
Shure:  红了这个灯
Shure: This light turned red
Jake: 你看看手机
Jake: Check your phone
Shure: 我是不是没删
Shure: Did I not delete it?
Jake: 你应该删了
Jake: You should've deleted it
Jake: 你看一看怎么回事
Jake: Check what's going on
Lucia: 这是
Lucia: This is
Lucia: 哎我这
Lucia: Oh, this
Lucia: 我这也到了一个
Lucia: I also got to a
Lucia: 到达养老院铁门请您在
Lucia: Arrived at the iron gate of the nursing home, please
Lucia: 系统环境存在异常
Lucia: System environment is abnormal
Jake: 没插上没摁
Jake: Didn't plug it in, didn't press it
Jake: 那就不知道了
Jake: Then I don't know
Jake: 那没关系
Jake: It's okay
Jake: 没关系你刚刚损失了点啥呀
Jake: It's okay, what did you just lose?
Shure:  我们俩唠嗑
Shure: We were just chatting
Jake: 那也行吧
Jake: That's fine too
Jake: 那是不是还是再重弹一遍
Jake: Should we play it again then?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay
Jake: 房间时候亮着吗
Jake: Was the room lit up?
Jake: 也不知道
Jake: No idea
Jake: 回头再说吧
Jake: We'll talk later
Jake: 反正没注意
Jake: Didn't really notice
Jake: 好嘞下回
Jake: Alright, next time.
Jake: 就是再说一遍
Jake: Just say it again.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 太引人入胜
Shure: So captivating.
Jake: 那得再录一遍
Jake: We have to record it again.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Nicous: 都出去看狗了
Nicous: Everyone went out to see the dog.
Shure:  就是把你们全知道
Shure: You all know it.
Shure:  我去看过
Shure: I went to see it.
Shure:  懂吗才能听这些
Shure: Understand it to listen to this.
Jake: 哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Lucia:哎呀我靠
Lucia: Oh my god.
Lucia:哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia:继续
Lucia: Keep going.
Jake:做狗
Jake: Play dead.
Jake:哎你也没电了
Jake: Oh, you're out of power too.
Lucia:做狗
Lucia: Play dead.
Lucia:我们需要笔
Lucia: We need a pen.
Jake:你没电了
Jake: You're out of power.
Tasha:我线呢
Tasha: Where's my cable?
Jake:在这吗找一找
Jake: Is it here? Look for it.
Lucia:只要我们有笔就可以做狗
Lucia: As long as we have a pen, we can play dead.